aquí tenemos dos números que queremos
sumar 327 y 251 ahora 327 eso significa
tres centenas tengo un tres en el lugar
de las centenas aquí lo puedes ver y
aquí tenemos tres centenas también mira
observa que cada uno de estos cuadros
grandes tiene 100 cuadros pequeños
entonces tenemos aquí tres estos cuatros
grandes eran tres centenas ahora
siguiente en el 327 tenemos al 2 el 2
está en el lugar de las decenas entonces
tenemos dos decenas ahí están y también
aquí lo puedes ver aquí tenemos dos
decenas cada una de estas figuras está
formada por diez cuadros pequeños así
que dos decenas y por último tenemos
siete en el lugar de las unidades
entonces tenemos siete unidades y bueno
aquí los puedes ver aquí tenemos un
total de siete unidades cada uno de
estos cuadros pequeños representan
unidad y tenemos siete de ellas ahí
están
así que 327 tenemos entonces tres
centenas aquí dos decenas y siete
unidades y a 327 le queremos sumar 251
otra manera de pensarlo es a 327 le
queremos sumar dos centenas vemos que el
2 está en el lugar de las centenas ahí
está y aquí tenemos estos dos cuatros
grandes
y simbolizan dos centenas cada uno de
estos cuadros grandes tiene 100 cuadros
pequeños entonces da un total de 2
centenas muy bien ahora el 5 está en el
lugar de las decenas y bueno aquí
tenemos 55 decenas lo escribo tenemos 5
decenas y aquí aquí las puedes ver son 1
2 3 4 5 decenas y por último el 1 está
en el lugar de las unidades entonces
bueno aquí está este cuadro simboliza
una unidad
y entonces ya que tenemos esto puedes
poner pausa al vídeo y puedes intentar
sumar estos dos números entonces bueno
vamos a suponer que ya lo hiciste que ya
intentaste sumar estos dos números y
hagamos esto juntos muy bien entonces
tenemos 7 unidades 7 unidades y le
queremos sumar una unidad entonces lo
que hacemos para saber cuántas unidades
tenemos es juntar las unidades sumarlas
entonces tenemos 7 unidades y una unidad
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 unidades en total
así que 7 unidades más una unidad es 8
unidades muy bien ahora vamos con las
decenas entonces sumamos las decenas
tenemos dos decenas y cinco decenas lo
que vamos a hacer es juntar las decenas
que sería hacer esto y vamos a sumar las
entonces que tenemos tenemos tenemos 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 decenas en total 2 decenas más
cinco decenas es 7 decenas
ahora vamos con las centenas entonces si
tienes tres centenas y le sumas dos
centenas esto te da un total de 325 si
las agrupamos a las centenas que aquí
están vemos que tenemos cinco centenas
en total así que lo que escribo es un 5
en el lugar de las centenas tres
centenas más dos centenas eso es igual a
cinco centenas por lo tanto vemos que si
sumamos estos dos números 327 + 251 eso
es igual a 578 y lo podemos ver aquí
representado 5 centenas 5 centenas siete
decenas siete decenas y ocho unidades
ocho unidades